you know I have to say I love this guy
from the fall which is fantastic series
I can't watch those films because I made
a movie with Dakota's mum I think used
to swing Dakota rhyme so I can't I just
can't
even though this is the the final film
it's the final film this is a bit of
sort of sergeants point everyone
you still don't go fully nude there's
still no fully nude even on set you
didn't go fully nude didn't fully know
why are you saying it like I think on
set I was fairly new but wasn't part of
the creative process the costume
department made sure you were not fully
nude okay so I don't know I'm sure you
guys had to deal with if you get these
we you get like a modesty patch for a
woman like a little so strip that goes
down there and for guys you gotta weep I
like looks like something Robin Hood
would carry coins in the first the first
time you do a sex scene and fifty Shades
of Grey the first movie or just what
four or five years ago no and I was a
I've never had to wear one of these for
whatever like and they had in my trailer
they had a little like display on the
box
yeah I know all all skin toned
[Laughter]
from small so I picked one I thought I
saw and lock my trailer door here try
this on wow that feels all right and
then I took it off my guess is all right
and that's it took it off it had a
little like stitch on the side said
inmate number three I have a love scene
I don't think it's an Excalibur they
shall put it back in that we have a
lovesick it'll be like historic now lads
I was on a suit of armor and it was
always out was cut I remember there was
a huge Eagle they had a big eagle
sitting on a preacher - yeah really bad
yes
yeah was it a real one yeah was a real
lady with me at the time
[Applause]
[Music]